[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
or as I prefer to think of a Dear John
and Hank it's a comedy podcast about
death in which me and my brother Joe and
answer your questions give you dubious
advice and bring you all the week's news
from both Mars and AFC Wimbledon hey
John how he'd do it I'm doing well it's
been a good week so far I've just been
playing FIFA's AFC Wimbledon I've been
writing a lot what else is going on this
week not much it's cold here in
Indianapolis we've had our first real
good solid snowfall and it's it's real
icy and intimidating I've been running a
lot I don't know things are good things
are really good how are you well the day
that we are recording this podcast oh it
is a week ago as you people listening to
it or maybe more than that but it was
the day that we found out that David
Bowie died and I'm very sad and having
I'm dealing with that indeed we must we
must pause to give thanks for the life
of David Bowie who was such a
astonishing revelation in so many worlds
not just music but in the way that he
presented himself in the way that he
shifted between identities truly a man
ahead of his time yes yes very helpful
for me to have David Bowie as a sort of
role model not in all things of course
but in many and I I'm sad so the local
radio station is is playing only David
Bowie on vinyl this day and I was just
sitting in my car very very hard to
leave that but here I am for dear Hank
and John comedy podcast about death so
appropriate today that couldn't couldn't
be a better day to do a comedy podcast
about death would you like a short poem
for the day I should have done something
David Bowie centric but I didn't Hank I
wasn't properly prepared that's fine I
accept your apology
instead I've got a Sonia Sanchez poem
for you today do you know Sonia Sanchez
she's a was born in Birmingham Alabama
my hometown not yours even though we're
brothers and great just just a brilliant
brilliant poet and one of one of the
best one of the best of love Poe poets
we have in the world today I think
although she also writes blisteringly
and and beautifully about race and and
sex and feminism and lots of other
things but this is a it's a very short
poem called black magic by Sonia Sanchez
magic my man is you turning my body into
a thousand smiles black magic is your
touch making me breathe
black magic by Sonia Sanchez short poem
very short poem for the day Hank I
thought I feel like I've been
lengthening the definition of short
poems yes lately on Dear John and Hank
and and I feel like I might be losing
some listeners in the process so go
check out Sonia Sanchez if you're not
familiar with her work it is full of
richness and it's just she's just a
wonderful wonderful poet yeah I don't
know next week Hank I'll have a poem for
you about grief how's that all well will
will will remember David Bowie a week
after his death which as listeners are
listening will be like six months after
is alright and I think with that it is
already time to start answering
questions it's only taking us like three
minutes it's unheard of John well I
don't know what to do I would like to
extend the intro to the podcast but I
have no I have no other short poems for
the day no and and I as sad as I am
don't want to harp on it especially
because everyone else is further along
in their process of grief than I am so
we've got a question from Henry who asks
dear Hank and John why our DVD covers
not square mmm that's a great question
hmm I think I know the answer you know I
think I can I can sum up the answer in
two words actually two words that you
might might disagree with but and that
the world
might disagree with okay but my two
words are Blockbuster Video okay I think
that you're wrong
respectfully but I think you're on the
right track
I think Blockbuster Video is part of why
DVDs are not square but I think the
actual deep down answer is VH are I
think that because video what sets I
think you've used the wrong and you used
the wrong three letters there I
apologize for interrupting really but
did you say vhr ECR oh I thought it said
vhr I don't think so did I did I say VC
I think I think you may have completed a
joint you can find the edges back at all
oh no I can't you are not allowed to
back it up just because you said
something wrong
everybody's gonna enjoy there's no way
we're gonna get out of there there's no
I'm gonna force Neil to edit this night
out it's a.m. it's great and all right
so tell me about VHS VCR video cassette
recorders my theory about why DVDs are
shaped the way they are is so they can
look more like VHS tapes that's where I
got the ants from because of VHS tapes
they can look more like VHS tapes be
similarly shaped so that when DVDs first
came out and I remember this vividly I
remember thinking but why would you want
to watch something on a CD it had the
advantage of being rectangular lis
shaped so that I could say to myself
well I don't like this business of
giving up video cassettes but I suppose
at least the shape is the same right and
I mean if you look at if you if they had
made them the sort of same form factor
as CDs everybody would have felt like I
was watching a movie on a CD whereas
they made it more the sort of size of
yeah more the height of a VHS tape and
also there's just something pleasing
about that aspect ratio it's the same
aspect ratio as a book and the reason
that books are that shape is you know
it's kind of a good good shape for
reading but also it's just very pleasing
to us that that like golden ratio shape
so I yeah I think it has to do entirely
with product marketing and and I would
love to know that
number of gallons of oil that were
necessary to make DVD cases that shape
rather than the shape they need they
they could have been which is much
smaller than they were but someone do
that calculation for me and then we can
all go uh and then move on well but it's
over Hank I mean the nice thing is that
every time we don't buy a DVD today we
save all of that oil that would have
gone into that plastic instead we just
downloaded for mine it's true it's true
I mean the number one question I have
for Henry is what our DVD is right
a lot of people listening to this are
okay this is a fascinating discussion
about two ancient pieces of technology I
have no relationship yeah yeah I mean
John couldn't even remember what a VHS
tape was called so that's gonna be
that's gonna be DVDs in ten years I'm
here ten years all right we've got
another question Hank this one is from
Avery who writes Dear John and Hank can
you set a cucumber on fire or is its
water content too high and therefore not
flammable that's a great question and
it's an important question because I
can't tell you how often I've looked at
a cucumber and thought I'm gonna charge
our at this mofo but then thought you
know what I'm not sure if that's
scientifically possible well John you
can definitely set a cucumber on fire
but you're gonna have to bake the water
out of it first yeah I mean a lot of
like that even when you're burning wood
sometimes the wood is wet and so you
throw it on there and then it steams for
a little while before it catches but
yeah there there is combustible material
inside of a cucumber but you would if
you dehydrated a cucumber you could
totally light it on fire and I don't
know how well it would burn I've never
tried but I bet you a dehydrated
cucumber would would burn very much like
a like a piece of wood now hey let me
ask you a related question have you ever
had a kool-aid pickle that is a cucumber
that has been pickled in kool-aid no I
well I have great now your life is about
to get better
because there is nothing on God's green
earth
as delicious as a kool-aid pick well I
have well how is my life about to get
better though because who's gonna give
me this kool-aid pickle well now that
you've asked for one lots of people I
bet every time we go on tour for the
next 10 years you'll get a kool-aid I
want to say to all those people who are
considering giving me a kool-aid pickle
whenever whenever I might show up in
your town please do not please bring me
a cookie I want two cookies that's uh I
do not want kool-aid pick I don't like
pickles I'm not a pickle guy I can have
some sweet relish on a hotdog but really
that's that's the extent of my pickle
interest I just vinegar is very strong
it's very strong flavor and I am NOT
into it John
so I died of course I'm a assume that
there's no vinegar in a kool-aid pickle
which makes me think that it's probably
going to spoil pretty quickly I don't
know I think there is vinegar in it
actually but I'm not I'm not a
scientific expert no kool-aid pickles
come to be all I know is that they taste
better than regular pickles but yeah
I've been thinking a lot about about
that about recently just because today
or yesterday actually as we're recording
this was the it was the four year
anniversary of the publication of my
book The Fault in Our Stars Hank and I
was thinking back to that tour in 2012
which was so fun but also so stressful
that for years all I could remember when
I thought about it was the anxiety that
it provoked and because we would sign
for several hours after the after the
event and that was I was pretty
overwhelming for me but one of my one of
my central memories from that is that is
that very kind lovely generous people at
every city that we went to they would
bring us peeps because one time in 2007
for those who don't know peeps are these
marshmallow like preservative filled
Easter yeah candies shaped like yellow
usually like yellow chicks but people
would bring us peeps because we made
some peeps jokes back in 2007 and and we
could never think of a polite way to say
the truth which is that we both hate
peeps that's the whole point that's why
we had to do the peeps because it was a
punishment it wasn't a punishment but it
was like it was like a challenge like ha
ha ha look at this person doing a thing
he does
exactly and then people are like yeah
they must love peeps so much but you
know people were people were you know
latching on to being a part of the
inside of this thing and and I
appreciate that but yeah we had a lot of
peeps that we we would take them to the
next place and then we would throw them
into the audience be like babe yeah well
just cuz some people like peeps and
those people got to enjoy this anyway
the-the-the the short version of this
very very long answer is that yes you
can light a cucumber on fire and yes
please bring Hank kool-aid pickles when
he's on tour he's by which he means
cookies but I do feel like next time we
go on tour we should bring a bunch of
peeps and we can throw them out in the
audience every single every single time
that would be fun it's a I feel like
that's sort of like a like a cheap safe
thing to throw into an audience you're
not gonna get hurt getting it hit in the
head with peeps no I've got another
question this one is from Sydney who
asks dear Hank and John if you're
standing on the moon does the earth ever
eclipse the Sun how often does this
happen and does it look as remarkable as
a lunar eclipse does from Earth more
importantly what most importantly what
does John think happens thank you for
the question Sydney so if you're
standing on the moon does the earth ever
eclipse the Sun the answer is of course
yes and in fact the earth eclipses the
Sun more often than the moon eclipses
the Sun for those of us standing on
earth you know John I actually duh I
don't know the answer to this question I
would have to look it up well my answer
was so confident that even if it is
incorrect people will believe me well I
think you're right like like based on
just base like I don't a hundred percent
no but based based on the fact that the
earth is bigger than the moon it
probably would eclipse the Sun more then
that then the moon does but I do I don't
know I yeah I don't know why I asked
this question without having looking up
a box alright let's move on to another
question then Hank said that you don't
have to continue to be embarrassed this
one is from Catrice who asks dear John
and Hank I know that both of you have
your own social feeds but have you ever
considered creating anonymous
profiles to be able to experience a
social network without the burden of
relative fame in other words are you
hiding as faceless social network users
among us this is a very interesting
question and I know a lot of people who
do you know I know I have a lot of sort
of you know famous ish friends or
acquaintances who have you know lives on
social networks that are you know
private because of the way that the way
that they structure them and because
they've never sort of been outed as as
being affiliated with that channel I
have one reddit account that I use just
to enjoy soccer anonymously without
having people you know jump in and talk
about other other stuff that I do that's
the only sort of non public facing
social identity that I have I guess I
mean my reddit account is people know
who I am but most people don't
and so the I just feel like reddit is a
sort of demographically different place
from most of the places that I spend
time on and my username is not my name
so usually I think that people like I
feel like just a normal person when I'm
using my reddit account unless I'm doing
an AMA or something so I like spend time
on like the personal finance subreddit
and the ulcerative colitis subreddit and
those people I'm just another person and
so I sort of get that experience that
way but yeah I mean honestly I spend so
much time doing social media as part of
like sort of you know it's it's part of
my job but it's a part that I enjoy
but like beyond that I don't want to do
a bunch of it because I do it all the
time all day anyway so I I sort of get
all of my social fix with the normal
with my like public social media inge
and I don't want any more of it after
that yeah I just wouldn't know how to do
it very well I don't you know I never I
never had
I never had a Twitter without an
audience I've had a website without an
audience like I feel like I know how to
write for a website you know as a as a
person who doesn't have much of a public
life but I don't I don't know how to do
it and I and I don't really want to
learn like I admire I admire people who
do it like there there are some Twitter
accounts that I follow that I just
followed because they're extremely
thoughtful and funny and engaging but
not because of whoever the person is who
runs it and in a way like that to me is
sort of the purest and most interesting
form of social media but it's not the
it's not that it's not the way that I've
ever used it so I I don't think I'd even
know where to begin
Aiden I've got another question John
it's from Aiden who asks dear Hank and
John is it always wrong to break the law
or certain laws meant to be broken
Doughboy still be a good person who
breaks the law no way well I don't have
any this is not a hard question for me
at all I'm surprised that you are
struggling with it
well I think the rule of law is actually
really important to the to the
maintenance of a social order but I do
let me let me let me give you an example
of of of times when it is okay to break
the law okay when the law when the law
breaks like fundamental human justice
things like for a very long time it was
illegal to be gay right and like and so
that in that case it is it is okay to
break that law now that law was not made
to be broken but I think it was
important that people broke that law I
think it's important that people break
break the like the prohibit prohibition
of marijuana laws because I don't think
that we'd be having a conversation about
the legalization of marijuana and about
the huge problem we have with mass
incarceration and people going to jail
for doing this thing that is not
dangerous to themselves or other people
and so I like I think that we need to
have that conversation and we wouldn't
be having it if people weren't breaking
that law right I agree with that and
certainly I mean obviously you're gonna
first off we have to just draw a line
between civil disobedience and other
kinds of law breaking like obviously you
know that
civil disobedience is often right and
often the the only correct or moral path
of action in the face of injustice like
obviously you know sit-ins during this
during the civil rights movement for
instance were important but that's
that's a different kind of breaking the
law because that's a kind of law
breaking the law where you understand
that you are breaking a law you are
choosing to break the law and then you
are you know suffering the legal
consequences so you're you're basically
sort of using the rule of law to bring
attention to the injustice of a law
that's different from smoking pot which
is against the law
yes but but you know usually you know
you smoke pot in the privacy of your own
home or whatever hoping not to get
caught and I but that said I agree with
you that it is not wrong to break the
law and that you are still a good person
if you break the law however we have to
understand that we're coming at that
conversation from a tremendous place of
privilege
you're 11 if you smoke pot you're 11
times more likely to be imprisoned if
you're african-american than if you're
white so it's it's relatively easy for
me to say you know that that it's that
it's okay or even you know that there's
nothing you know wrong with breaking the
law when I am very unlikely to receive
the kind of harsh punishments that have
that have been this like great disgrace
of mass incarceration in the United
States I think it's a lot more
complicated to tell someone who's in a
position where they could go to jail for
25 years that they should smoke pot if
they want to like I think that but
that's not want to lose you don't want
to lose in the conversation the the real
risks that people run when they break
laws and they aren't in privileged
positions right and that that is
entirely the reason why I was ant
like when I was growing up I was
anti-drugs almost exclusively because I
knew that it could mess up my future
which is but that is not a reason to not
break the law
I mean it is but but that is not the
question that Aidan is asking Aidan is
asking is it always wrong to break the
law and the answer is no it is not
always wrong to break the law and and it
is not oh it is probably not a good idea
but that does not change the fact that
it is not wrong right I just want people
I yeah but I just want to be conscious
of the fact that there are you know
potentially catastrophic consequences to
some people and that those consequences
are unfairly distributed among the
population yes I agree with the only
other thing I would say about that is
that I actually don't think it's always
wrong to break just laws it's just that
they have to be exceptionally minor ones
and the circumstances have to dictate it
for instance I think that that speed
limit laws are good that we should have
more of them in fact but occasionally
it's okay to speed like you know if yeah
one time I one time I got food stuck in
my esophagus and so I couldn't swallow
any any water couldn't swallow any
liquid I decided to drive myself to the
hospital and I would throw up every like
five or ten seconds cuz you just he was
producing so much saliva trying to get
this piece of food down my esophagus but
then my esophagus you know couldn't
handle it so it would just come back up
and I thought it was okay to speed in
that situation just because like I
really did kind of need to get to the
hospital
and it worked out for me so Aidan oh man
if the question is John and Hank there
is food in my esophagus I cannot get it
down or up is it okay to speed I'm gonna
say a cautious yes yeah and I do think
that this is a problem with laws like we
want to have assists and we need to have
a system where there are like there are
rules and sometimes the rules get broken
in ways where everybody is like well I
understand why that happened but we have
to enforce the law and that can cause
big big problems you know especially
when like the letter of the law is
different from the intent of the law
that that does happen sometimes where
you know you you have a law that was
built for one situation being applied to
a new situation that it clearly does
apply to but that it was not intended to
address and that's why that's one of the
many reasons why legal systems are
complicated and why you have to go to
school for a real long time to be a
lawyer yeah I mean it's also just
another example of how to me to me the
whole the whole legal system at least in
the u.s. like it's just a great example
of how power sort of concert' conserves
and preserves itself yeah
very efficiently and effectively because
once you're inside of the legal system
like if you're if you're on parole for
instance like everything just becomes
much more complicated and challenging
it's just so much easier to go back to
jail but if you're never inside of the
system then it seems that the system is
quite effective because you can point to
you know lower crime rates over the last
thirty years and lots of other stuff but
then once you're inside of the system
it's just it's tremendously dehumanizing
and and and also you know it's it's it's
one of the places where class and race
and and and sex are just most obviously
you know the data is just overwhelming
that they play huge roles in what
happens to people who commit offenses
that are that are deemed to be illegal
sorry I'll get off my soapbox now and
answer another question Dear John up
this question this question is from
Sophie who writes Dear John and Hank I'm
a high school senior in the midst of the
college application turmoil my parents
think I have a delusion of grandeur
about being able to make a lasting
impact in the world should I be
realistic and why does being realistic
mean I have to give up on my dreams of
doing something amazing
don't do it just believe in yourself
everybody can everybody makes big
changes on the people around them at the
very least and also maybe on the whole
world and I think that having dreams is
fantastic and I think that but I also
think that refining those dreams as you
go on is absolutely okay too so having
something that drives you forward is not
something that you should not engage
with like have that thing Drive you
forward and if suddenly if it like it
becomes clear that that thing isn't
isn't necessarily gonna happen that's
okay don't move go in a different
direction have a new thing that drives
you forward but I you know I think you
know being able to make a lasting impact
on the world that's not that's not
delusional right John no quite the
opposite I'm reading this book about
ancient Rome actually and the writer
keeps saying you know like something
will happen in ancient Rome and then the
writer will say and the world would
never be the same and I just keep
thinking but like after everything that
happens the world is never the same you
know what I mean like the you know after
I finished playing a game of Wimbley
wombly Zahn FIFA 16 the world will never
be the same the world will never be the
same after you have kids the world will
never be the same after you get married
the world will never be the same after
every event in in human history so I
guess for me the it's a false it's a
false choice between being realistic and
being able to make a difference because
there are so many ways to make a
difference I do believe in being
realistic about your dreams but I also
believe in having those dreams I believe
in like finding ways to make them make
them realistic rather than just just
agreeing when you're told that you know
that things like that don't happen to
people like you they do whatever it is
whatever the dream is things like that
do happen to people like you unless the
dream is of becoming a banana and
floating in space
all the way to Mars yes we've already
learned that it takes way too much
energy to get out of the Earth's
atmosphere in the first place why do you
always bring up the atmosphere because
it just infuriates you it does it does
yeah I mean we've got a very thick
atmosphere Hank it's hard to swim
through doing big things it it I I think
that the the number one thing is to not
tie your self-worth up in this in a
quest to make some magnificent impact
and yeah like that's maybe that's what
your parents are trying to protect you
from the potential that like you'll get
so like you will believe that you are
not a worthwhile person unless you have
this kind of impact and I think a lot of
us are we kind of are taught that the
people that we hear about in the media
that people that are idealized whether
that's a businessperson or a celebrity
are people that seem to have outsized
impact on the world like greater than
average impacts and and and so we we
sort of like we we tie that to to like
what makes a person a person worthwhile
so it is possible that like you know
don't don't think that that is the only
way to be a worthwhile person that is
absolutely not the case
but yes do want to have impacts on the
world do want to make the world a better
place and do make decisions based on
that you know based on the the change
that you want to make in the world have
that be a guiding force in the decisions
that you make whether that's what school
you go to or what you do on a Friday
night and yeah that's that's absolutely
okay to do it's always been seem so
weird to me that people put so much
emphasis on celebrity and I know that I
know that like I'm you know coming at
this from a particular perspective and
everything but
but that said like I just don't believe
that celebrities have some massive
impact on you know the social order
that quote-unquote regular people don't
have like if you want to have a lasting
big impact on the social order be a
teacher because when you're 75 years old
and you're still teaching 15 year olds
those 15 year olds are going to remember
you for another 60 years you know those
15 year olds are gonna remember you when
you would have been a hundred and
thirty-five or whatever no one is going
to remember the vast majority of like
so-called celebrities when they would be
a hundred and seventy-five years old
Hank who is the guy who was on that show
Charles in Charge
Scott Baio when we were kids Scott Baio
was phenomenally famous I wanted to be
Scott Baio worse than I've ever wanted
anything in my life and I just even
though it's only been 20 years nearly
forgot his name yep yeah I sing the song
about Helen Hunt who is the biggest
biggest star on TV when I was a young
person and I will sing this song about
Helen Hunt and and the majority of the
people in the room will not know who
Helen on this which is just a tragedy
she's wonderful it is a tragedy but I
have to say because both Helen Hunt and
Scott Baio are just phenomenally
important people in human history well I
have to say
and they're also old friends of the
podcast so hi Helen hi Scott thanks for
listening we appreciate your support
keep sending in your questions will
answer one someday I I have to say that
like I think that in some ways you make
a choice between having a having a sort
of a deep impact on people's lives and
having a broad impact and celebrities
are always celebrated in part for having
such a broad impact but a lot of times I
feel like it isn't a deep impact and
we've talked before Hank about how the
only following worth having is a cult
following and I deeply deeply believe
that because you know the the sort of
cult cult-like
institutions that I've followed over the
years whether it's they might be giants
or the mountain goats or or the mr. t
experience or say Frank and when he was
making this show you know those are the
things that have had the biggest impact
on the way that I think about life and
and the things that I found most helpful
in in the darkest times didn't get me
through and nothing against Scott Baio
or Helen Hunt but like I haven't turned
to their to them in in my darkest hour
the way I've turned for instance to John
Darnielle of the mountain goats agreed
agreed
I have another question John it's from
Alex who asks dear Hank and John I'm
Alex from Maryland my friend chase
recently told me how great the podcast
is so far I'm loving it welcome to the
podcast Alex my question is is
mayonnaise an instrument I think that
this might have something to do with
spawn
I googled it yeah and but spongebob
seems to think that mayonnaise is not an
instrument now I don't know any of the
context of this argument but I will say
that I think anything can be an
instrument and if you want proof of that
you can go to watch songs to wear pants
to the YouTube channel where Andrew
Huang does play music with just about
anything he recently played a symphony I
think something bye-bye one of the
classical composers with thongs you know
on the underpants and I think that if
you can play a classical piece a piece
of music with thongs then you can play
something with mayonnaise my answer to
this question would be that that
mayonnaise is certainly an instrument
it's an instrument of horror and
destruction and sadness I see what I see
what you mean I love it mayonnaise and I
don't know what's wrong with you what do
you mean you love man is I mean that I
think that mayonnaise is a condiment
that I enjoy putting on various salty
type foods are you kidding you you like
you put mayonnaise on a sandwich
sure Oh God really that's what
mayonnaise is that was that's what
mayonnaise was created for that's what
humans do with mayonnaise that is
literally the thing that is done with
Matt and I mean like potato salad egg
salad all these many salad dressings are
often made with mayonnaise how is this
and how is this a surprise can't believe
you like man it's man like if you told
me if you just suddenly announced that
you know you believed deep down that the
greatest football club in the world was
Manchester United like I just cannot
believe that someone I've counted on for
so many years and been so close to all
this time has been liking mayonnaise I
mean were you not around for my
childhood that's what I ate I ate ham
and mayonnaise sandwiches I would not
eat anything else
Oh God ham and mayonnaise sandwiches I
first off I wasn't around for your
childhood I went to boarding school when
you were 10 that just sounds awful why
would you eat ham and mayonnaise
sandwiches when you could put mustard on
that sandwich is the same what mustard
oh my god I don't know how people do
mustard it's just like it's just like
just
just dirt mixed up in vinegar I mean
mustard is one of the great tastes on
earth and mayonnaise is one of the worst
mayonnaise is something like I sometimes
I opened my refrigerator and I'll see
that we have a jar of mayonnaise in
there and I'll be like why do we own
this this is reprehensible I probably
went out of date in like 2011 I just
haven't gotten it out of the fridge
mayonnaise man is glass a real long time
it's one of the remarkable things about
yeah I wonder why maybe it's because
it's made of preservatives but it just
it lasts forever I would actually like
to know why mayonnaise last so long
someone should ask that to the podcast
and we could answer it sometime after I
do some research all right well in the
meantime Hank we have to move on from
this horrifying discussion to the news
of Mars and AFC Wimbledon I want to say
the only time mustard is good is when
it's mixed with mayonnaise oh god it's
just that's the fastest way to ruin
mustard its I think that that's most
salad dressings it's just mayonnaise and
mustard mixed together right that's why
I don't that's why I don't eat creamy
salad dressings nor does anyone who has
any kind of sophisticated palate do you
think that it's already time for the
news from Mars because I don't think it
is I think it's time I think it's time
to talk about our sponsors John because
this episode of dear Hank and John is
brought to you by mayonnaise mayonnaise
creamy delicious goodness made with
whole eggs nope nope nope this podcast
is not brought to you by mayonnaise it's
brought to you man Ava
mustard mustard delicious nutritious and
no eggs in it
zero zero calories and mustard it is the
opposite literal opposite of nutritious
this podcast is also brought to you by
breaking the law breaking the law it's
it does not make you a bad person
sometime I mean first off nothing not
necessarily does not necessarily make
you a bad person and of course this
podcast is brought to you by DVDs DVDs a
technology that most of you are not
familiar with that's not true everybody
knows what a DVD is still the other day
I asked my I asked Siri a question
because I was curious if my we would
play DVDs uh-huh so I asked TV I asked
Siri just what my we play Netflix and
then I said oh I mean no DVDs and Siri
understood all of those words Wow but I
I was at the point where I accidentally
called DVDs Netflix yeah well I don't
blame you
that is so Wow okay and remarkably Siri
gave me the correct answer to that
question but Siri which is um knows my
we cannot play DVDs it doesn't surprise
me yeah why would it be able to play
DVDs and NIC if you could just cut off
this boring crap out of the podcast that
would be great what are you talking
about I think that's you what you just
did John is I made I told a story that I
thought was funny yeah and then you said
Nick can you cut that boring crap out of
the podcast don't hurt my feelings all
right well and to be fair I think I've
talked for 85% of this episode of dear
Hank and John so you should probably be
allowed to ramble on a bit all right
John I guess it is now time for the news
from both Mars and AFC Wimbledon I got a
little bit of Mars news do you got a
little bit of AFC Wimbledon news I do
but only a little bit it's been a quiet
week for AFC Wimbledon as as the the
senior team has has not
played this week in fact I haven't
played since January 2nd they have a
game against Carlisle that was postponed
because the FA Cup however Hank the AFC
Wimbledon under-18 team played Premier
League side Newcastle last week
Newcastle are like they're one of the
biggest teams in England and AFC
Wimbledon won 2-1 thanks to two goals
from a ginger a 17 year old ginger Hank
whose name is Alfie Alfie Egan 17 year
old Alfie Egan scored two goals against
New Castle's under-18 team to send the
under 18 AFC Wimbledon team all the way
through to the sixth round of the FA
Youth Cup where they will face either
Chelsea or Manchester United is that not
unbelievable I cannot believe it I can't
believe that we have a ginger on our
books named Alfie Egan the future could
not be brighter I'm so pleased I don't
know what it means but I have news for
you John alright about Mars kind of the
Martian won a Golden Globe for Best
picked for best comedy it was ended up
being a comedy there are funny parts
oh but it did win a Golden Globe so
that's good so that's the news for bars
is that this movie about Mars
won a Golden Globe in his yeah yay in
his acceptance speech Ridley Scott
talked at length about the importance of
Mars exploration and how there was no
future for humans where we did not
continue to reach for further further
life afield and how we needed to go to
Mars and there was widespread agreement
among the all the Hollywood people all
right well that's that to me sounds like
a comedy movie to me I made all of that
up Ridley Scott didn't talk about any of
them oh I don't watch TV so I wouldn't
know but if we can call this a comedy
podcast though the Martian can can win a
Golden Globe for Best Comedy I will say
I didn't think the margin was the best
comedy of the year but I did think it
was one of the best movies I've seen
this year
I have to say I thought it was much
better than that then the revenant which
won a lot of ya Awards last night which
is a very like just an unfathomably
violent movie about a bear but usually
you would think that I would like
because I love violence and I love bears
but I just I didn't I didn't find the
combination that appealing in this
particular instance mMmmm interesting
interesting I I thought that the
revenant was about a Leonardo DiCaprio
just leo play the bear leo does not play
the bear he plays a man who gets mauled
by a bear
the issue with the revenant really is
that it's not about anything except for
survival and a pure desire for revenge
which is I like I I don't find these
revenge fantasy movies to be compelling
in and of themselves it's beautiful
cinema and everything and the
cinematography is amazing
Leonardo DiCaprio is brilliant in and of
course he's very good actor but I just
felt that there was no there there if
you get my drift yeah I I went to see
Star Wars again this weekend and the
people that I saw star was with a number
of the
stayed to then watch the revenant
immediately afterward and I found that
to be a questionable decision also it's
a question illipe questionable legality
unless they paid for both movies they
did play at it they did have to move to
a different theater yes no good that is
one of those cases where probably you
shouldn't break the law if you're just
stealing and I haven't don't do that ah
and as they say in the previews every
single time with that guy in the hoodie
who's filming the movie on his iPhone
that is illegal - so don't Hank what did
we learn today we are we learned that
John if you try hard enough you can set
anything on fire it's not actually true
not anything though you cannot set
helium on fire or any of the noble gases
that's why I live in a world full of
helium you must have a real deep voice
this is your helium voice we also
learned that DVDs are shaped like VA
chars or vcs's we can't remember neither
can we remember Scott Baio very much
anymore but I'm sure that both he and
Helen Hunt are having a lovely go of it
and of course I don't even know what to
say after that what does that even mean
having a lovely go of it life you know
Helens working on movies and she's
always doing I just don't have note was
nominated for an Oscar a few years ago
she's great she's has a great career and
of course we learned that if you're on
the moon the earth may eclipse the Sun
but don't trust John he got a c-minus in
both physics and chemistry and biology
and that question is probably one of
those because it seems like a science
question and those were the only science
but those are all the those are the
science well okay I see I see how you
see the world
thank you for podcasting with me John I
hope that people enjoyed this as much as
I do yeah thanks for listening everybody
you can email us
questions at Hank and John at gmail.com
or you can use the hashtag on Twitter
hashtag dear Hank and John I'm John
Green on Twitter Hank is Hank green you
can also follow us on other social media
most notably for Hank is snapchat Hank
gr e and most notably for me my reddit
I'm not giving you the idea I'm not
gonna need the username I'm sorry this
podcast is edited by Nicholas Jenkins
the theme music is from gunnarolla and
as they say in our hometown don't forget
to be awesome
[Music]